Mike where do you want to start wherever
you want to start dan how about my hot
take that brought the fire department
here to the man cave where I talked
about I see a scenario where Tony Romo
with the Cowboys have clinched
home-field advantage throughout is going
to get some playing time that's all too
hot for me Wow yeah here's why I think
they want to keep the guy healthy than a
trade him in the offseason and the thing
about Tony Romo when he plays he tends
to get injured so he's healthy you only
use him if you absolutely positively
have to use them and also I'm not so
sure they're going to have home-field
advantage clench bye week 17 there are
two games ahead of the giants but the
Giants have beaten them once the Giants
play them again sunday night football
week 14 and the Giants otherwise only
have to make up one game and the next
thing you know the Cowboys could be not
the champions of the NFC east so I'm not
sure they're going to have that luxury
but even if they do I don't think you
want to put Tony Romo out on the field
you are a hot take toppers what you are
right there I'd you ask me a question I
answered it okay fair enough re don't
get sensitive here I'm not sensitive
feels like that I'm sensitive about
being censored oh no way to have a
quarterback of a certain team that all
will you stop everything's good with
Aaron Rodgers now right hey they're
gonna win the division people think I'm
crazy for saying that and there's plenty
of evidence that i am but even though
the packers are two games behind the
lines they've already beaten Alliance
and the lines have a very tough schedule
coming up they play at Norland at the
giant at the Cowboys all the Packers
have to do Dan is make up one game over
the next four weeks and week 17 is
winner take all and it's worth playoff
play in game probably the game that will
have on sunday night football cuz you
know the NFL like to have that game that
is a postseason game a de facto playoff
game and people think it's not because
the Lions are 74 and their win all these
game and the Packers think the Packers
got together on monday night and if they
keep it together I think they're gonna
win that division would you be willing
to spin the wheel of punishment on this
program if the Cowboys don't win the
division no no no
oh god no I've seen the outside material
there better be a damn good on the
upside for me to risk a wheel of
punishment the NFL in London are they
changing the starting time of that game
in London from 9 30 til one o'clock well
the wall street journal reported
yesterday that they are and the NFL has
yet to come out and say that it's
incorrect so I'm assuming that they are
ditching that extra window that makes
for 14 hour days of football three times
a year and if it was drawing big ratings
then they would keep doing it they love
it then because it puts NFL games live
in prime time in Asia so that's one of
the benefits of playing the game at nine
thirty a.m. eastern time but how
ludicrous it is to have a game that
starts involving the RAM at 630am los
angeles time so those london games are
going to get subsumed back within the
early window that's the report from The
Wall Street Journal the NFL's yet to
debunk it so I it looks like that's
going to happen and I think that was
leaked yesterday because probably today
and it's not today very soon the NFL
will announce the three games to be
played next year in London and then we
have thursday night on NBC where it's
the Vikings and the Cowboys it was joe
flint from The Wall Street Journal who
had that report yesterday the future of
thursday night football is what well you
know i'm told that the NFL is going to
take a look at limiting or eliminating
thursday night football and NFL has
tried to debunk that report and most
recently jerry jones the cowboys owner
said on radio in dallas that the NFL is
fully committed to thursday night
football ok the fact that they won't
even discuss it if that's accurate and i
believe it's not accurate it's counter
to everything else that's going on right
now at 345 park avenue they're trying to
figure out how to solve this ratings
issue and one problem dan when you've
got 51 primetime games per year that's
nearly twenty percent of the entire
schedule that is played in prime time
what does primetime mean it means prime
not the Browns not the Jaguars all due
respect not the bad teams it can't be
bad teams in
time people aren't going to tune in for
bad teams in prime time they'll tune in
for good teams in prime time the problem
is you can't you can't fill a supply of
thursday night football every single
week with all of the good teams because
it's unfair to play on Sunday and then
turn around and play on Thursday so that
effort to keep it fair for all 32 teams
means every team plays a short week game
once per year which means teams that
shouldn't be in prime time are in prime
time and at some point the NFL has got
to figure that out you can't expect
people to tune in in big numbers to
watch teams that don't belong in prime
time right Harrison made the point a
couple of weeks ago it used to be had to
earn a prime-time game the NFL needs to
get back to that point if it wants huge
audiences the audiences are smart enough
now to not tune in at night time to
watch a game that isn't worthy of a of a
large audience tuning in I I gave you a
hot take you return serve there you
ready for a cold take I'll take whatever
take you want to give me Paulie give
Mike Florio your cold take envoy Mike's
in a tear this up what if the NFL moved
the thursday night games to Friday night
then you alleviate the short turn around
a little bit and you take out the player
safety debate give teams more time to
prepare and the games on Friday night
even though it's not a hot night for TV
people can stay up later and watch the
entire game East Coast Midwest yeah but
the problem is it's not going to
generate big ratings because people out
on Friday nights and you can't do it
until after the first weekend in
December because the broadcast antitrust
exemption from the early 60s that lets
the NFL sell all of its TV rights in
bulk and not one team at a time
specifically hinges on not playing on
saturdays or fridays from labor day
until early december so that's why they
don't do that and that's why we just get
those little snippets of saturday games
in december and that used to be a big
deal yeah right that was special i mean
i think back in the 70 you didn't see
much football and you'll wanted more and
now when i talk to people and personally
dan I like having standalone games you
know how hard it hard it is on sundays
at one o'clock when we're watching eight
nine games at a time at NBC it's hard to
keep up with all those games at once I'd
like to watch one of the time but now
the people I talked to who are fans who
who like the sport they think that
there's too much
in the 70s there wasn't enough now
there's too much they need to strike the
right balance what bowling so you're
seen as a chance in December it would be
a good idea for December and one thing
that they're going to look at and again
the NFL can dispute it all they want
thursday night football beginning after
thanksgiving yes and then you make the
schedule in april with teams that you
are confident are going to draw an
audience no matter how good or bad their
season may go cowboys patriots
big-ticket big audience teams no Browns
sorry brows and maybe someday it will be
the brows every team should aspire that
this one of the rewards of being a good
team but people aren't going to tune in
on a consistent basis to watch the
mediocre and bad teams better hear you
or shifter uh well mine because I know
it's real I don't know what he's got wow
what I haven't had a chance oh my god
chef d hairpiece what I don't know that
hairline looks a little manufactured wow
that is a hat looks like a row crops to
me at times dan man is the same the fire
department may come back check the door
the fire department could come back good
god you just blew the roof off this
place the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience